the vast majority of news in the u.s. is
controlled by five huge corporations and
news voice is fighting back against
media monopolies it's the first-ever
entirely open crowd-sourced democratized
platform for news use the link right
underneath this video to download the
news voice app for free
Tuesday night we were told that Donald
Trump was not going to be addressing the
nation about the strike by Iran on two
American bases in Iraq but yesterday
Donald Trump did address the nation and
it was a bizarre rambling confused
dishonest speech but the one upside to
the speech is that it does seem Donald
Trump is not planning to immediately
escalate with Iran into a full-scale war
we should all be happy about that now
before we get into this especially
because there's some stuff in the speech
that's funny in the way that Trump
sometimes makes us laugh so that we
don't cry but this is very serious stuff
people's lives are on the line here
people's lives are also on the line with
health care and immigration and many
issues but they're on the line here in a
very specific way we are a laughingstock
with this guy as the president and we
don't want to forget the seriousness of
this even when we watch the wacky parts
here so let's start with Donald Trump's
opening line which is Iran will never
have nuclear weapon as long as I'm
president of the United States Iran will
never be allowed to have a nuclear
weapon now we're all thrilled that no
one was harmed but it is sort of a
strange place to start and the big thing
that the trumpets are pointing to in
this speech is that Donald Trump says
Iran is standing down our great American
forces are prepared for anything
Iran appears to be standing down which
is a good thing for all parties
concerned and a very good thing for the
world
no American or Iraqi lives were lost
because of the precautions taken the
dispersal of forces
and an early warning system that worked
very well right-wingers are loving this
because to them Donald Trump saying Iran
is standing down is a sign that Donald
Trump has won that Trump is the Alpha
that Trump has dominated Iran because he
says Iran is standing down now of course
this is very much in the eye of the
beholder Trump killed General Kasim
soleimani Iran bombed two bases and both
parties are now saying if you don't keep
going we won't keep going it's not
exactly standing down but the trumpets
are claiming some kind of weird victory
when in reality there are no winners
here certainly not here in the United
States where Donald Trump is still
president now let's get to a part of the
statement by Donald Trump it is sort of
hard to hear and understand Trump often
in the speech because of the amount of
sniffing I read that he sniffed 85 times
during the speech something was going on
with his nose but try to understand what
Trump says here Iran's hostilities
substantially increased after the
foolish Iran nuclear deal was signed in
2013 and they were given 150 billion
dollars not to mention 1.8 billion
dollars in cash so he's blaming Obama of
course but this 150 billion that Iran
was given is a farce it's far less than
that that's been fact checked but the
real moment that I want to get to in the
blame obama part of the speech is this
next one the missiles fired last night
at us and our allies were paid for with
the funds made available by the last
administration the regime also greatly
tightened the reins on their own country
even recently killing 1,500 people at
the many protests paid for with funds
made available by the Obama
administration that is the extremely coy
language and deceptive language it was
Iranian money that we had put a hold on
and the hold was released as part of the
nuclear deal it's extraordinarily
disingenuous and deceptive to say that
that that in any way was the u.s. giving
Iran money that's like saying if
you owe someone $100 but you're holding
the hundred dollars and you give it to
them and then they go and take that
hundred bucks and buy drugs to say you
were responsible for them buying drugs
as a stretch it's a very childish notion
you were holding the money for them now
Trump is putting in place immediate
sanctions on Iran he says that amid more
of this constant sniffing we continue to
evaluate options in response to Iranian
aggression the United States will
immediately impose additional punishing
economic sanctions on the Iranian regime
these powerful sanctions will remain
until Iran changes its behavior
in recent months alone Iran se ships in
international waters fired an unprovoked
strike on Saudi Arabia and shot down two
US drones and then of course maybe the
biggest news and this is something we
should be glad about and I'll talk later
about the context of this Donald Trump
does not appear to be escalating
offering sort of an olive olive branch
to Iran in the shared goal of the
destruction of Isis al Baghdadi was
trying again to rebuild the Isis
Caliphate and failed tens of thousands
of Isis fighters have been killed or
captured during my administration Isis
is a natural enemy of Iran the
destruction of Isis is good for Iran and
we should work together on this and
other shared priorities finally to the
people and leaders of Iran we want you
to have a future and a great future one
that you deserve one of prosperity at
home and harmony with the nations of the
world and then one Donald Trump off the
rails moment again being called
everything from a sign of a neurological
issue to who knows what Donald Trump
mentions a compliment a compliment
shades a compliment shades not sure if
that's a window dressing or a political
outcome take a look over the last three
under my leadership our economy is
stronger than ever before and America's
achieved energy independence these
historic accomplishment shades our
strategic priorities these are
accomplishments that nobody thought were
possible very odd moment so overall the
speech was filled with Donald Trump's
lies blaming Obama shirking
responsibility false claims of success
but it does seem that Iran's ploy in a
sense worked Iran retaliated they got a
response to the assassination of Kasim
soleimani on the record but they gave
Donald Trump a way out Trump also
believes that he won he got Kasim
Soleimani Iran retaliated but didn't
kill anybody
so is this all good well the X Factor is
that Donald Trump wants all of this to
help him get reelected to distract from
impeachment if nothing else happens the
conversation goes right back to Donald
Trump being an impeached president to
Donald Trump as a vulnerable incumbent
president that's where we are today we
should all be glad that it appears as
though there's not going to be a further
escalation but what I want to talk about
later today and we're going to talk
about next is the fact that Trump backed
away from a problem he created can't be
seen as an administration this is like
taking credit for putting out a fire
that you started I think it was Bernie
Sanders who used that metaphor and
that's what I want to talk about next